boa tarde galera todo mundo dormindo já
não é bom o meu nome é fernando alberto
eu sou o político com muito orgulho né
ninguém jogou nada então tá bom a nossa
classe ela está um pouco injustiçado
digamos assim é não é também falar das
vezes mas é isso que a gente precisamos
de pessoas para mudar isso então vou
trazer para vocês hoje um pouco da minha
história né do que eu passei nem eu nem
sempre fui político não nasci
as pessoas acham as vezes que políticos
na assembléia políticos né
como em várias famílias grandes aí ó em
torno do brasil mas tem exemplos de
pessoas que não nascem políticas e se
tornam políticos né eu garanto que aqui
dentro hoje tem muitos políticos neinha
todo mundo tem um papel importante
então vamos vamos trabalhando isso aliás
tem um detalhe eu em dois anos primeiro
mandato né
já após pedir música no fantástico já
estou no terceiro processo de cassação
me né então todo mundo sabe o último foi
criticado e mais o prefeito então
infelizmente quando a gente começa a se
voltar contra o sistema o sistema também
se volta contra a gente
[Música]
eu queria que a gente pensasse
imaginasse se a gente tivesse um grande
poder mágico cada um de vocês aqui né
que não precisa ser a varinha do harry
potter mas se cada um tivesse um poder
nas suas mãos e pudesse mudar alguma
coisa
qual seria a primeira coisa que você
mudaria mas imagina assim gente no não
haja uma coisa sua mas imagino contexto
em que você vive dentro da universidade
onde você onde você estuda a onde você
mora no bairro quais são os problemas
que você enfrenta um problema de acesso
à saúde tem problema de segurança de
educação e se você tivesse um poder de
mudar qualquer uma dessas realidades uma
varinha mágica então que você no estalo
de dedos
você mudaria pense agora refeita qual é
a primeira coisa que você mudaria pensou
quem pensou em mudar o seu comportamento
[Música]
vocês já pensaram que o poder de mudar
qualquer coisa nós temos ele mas a gente
não usa a gente deixa ele muitas vezes
parado ou por omissão ou a gente vota e
acha que a pessoa que está eleita lá vai
resolver tudo que por exemplo assim a
gente elege um prefeito e acha que ele
vai passar quatro anos e vai fazer
aquilo que eu espero que ele faça ou que
se eu estivesse lá eu faria
a gente simplesmente abandona não é quem
já viu essa essa imagem aqui que se você
perguntar só quem quer mudanças
quem quer mudança aqui pessoal americano
quem quer um país melhor que em que a
educação melhora todo mundo quer é ter
alguém que não quer mas agora quem está
disposto a mudar de verdade a participar
disso né
a parte ser parte dessa mudança a dar o
exemplo e essa reflexão principal que a
gente vai vai ter hoje aqui eu nem
sempre eu sou político apenas dois anos
eu sou eu comecei a trabalhar com 13
anos de idade
[Música]
o empreendedor logo cedo com 15 anos eu
já desenvolvia softwares para locadoras
em cascavel mesmos o gaúcho de cruz alta
mas moro em cascavel desde 92
com 17 anos eu abri minha primeira
empresa que era uma empresa de criação
de sites e 99 nessa época não se tinha
tantas empresas assim estava no primeiro
ano de faculdade e logo em seguida no
outro ano eu abandonei ficando tarde né
então mas não é pra vocês fazem isso não
é esse o exemplo o retorno mas enfim nós
tivemos hoje que parece também sobre
modelos de ensino
enfim eu acabei depois tendo mais uma
empresa sempre mais tecnologia foi um
dos precursores de software livre
aqui no país tive no primeiro encontro
mundial de software livre em curitiba
'nesse trabalhei nessa parte de linux
banco de dados
mas enfim a informática nos leva também
por um caminho fora da rede acadêmica
enfim eu tive alguns problemas com o uso
de drogas foi usuário de cocaína muitos
anos né foi preso e as pessoas olham
assim é não me julgam por causa disso me
julgou hoje eu sou político
o vereador é nessa hora que bom galera
tão gente boa e virou político né mas da
cadeia em falar a água é mas enfim isso
me levou de certa forma depois que
passei que superei isso aí é uma
superação diária então já tô limpo aí há
quase dez anos comecei a participar mais
da sociedade eu tinha que buscar meios
de participar e comecei a me interar
comecei a participar de uma entidade
chamada jc e júnior chamber
international que inclusive nós temos
uma kim em cidade de leste e tem no
brasil em alguns lugares do brasil e no
mundo inteiro mais de 120 países né a
com isso comecei a participar também um
chamado conselho comunitário de
segurança em cascavel e representar a
jcn eu até pensei poxa mas eu acabei de
sair alguns alguns meses da cadeia né e
já voltar lá no conselho de segurança
fazendo o que eu falei mas eu vou né
gente eu não sou bandido né
foi apenas um usuário né e fui
participar
alguns dias depois precisava de uma vaga
para representar o conselho de segurança
em um outro conselho que é um conselho
municipal de políticas públicas sobre
drogas e nenhuma dessas pessoas sabia da
minha história porque eu não preciso
ficar mostrando pra todo mundo aquilo
que eu passei eu não preciso usar uma
camiseta dizendo senhor fui usuário nem
olha foi preso não é de estudo quando
foi carregado na minha
e agora eu também né e eu não e hoje
falo aqui para mostrar o meu exemplo
apenas isso é uma coisa que eu comento
no dia-a-dia a e ponderei sobre essa
questão falei olha um conselho sobre
drogas né
enfim fui participar é claro que
chegando à quem que entendia do assunto
era eu obviamente né anos de experiência
né gente
como é que você não vai entender do
assunto em seis meses eu me tornei o
presidente então do concelho
e aí um dia depois chegou um papel pra
mim assinar um papel assinado é um papel
que é concedida então a permissão para o
prefeito para fazer o plano o secretário
fazer alguma coisa eu comecei o papel
que não é bem assim e eu não fazia ideia
gente do que que era um conselho de
direito de políticas públicas
não tinha a menor noção de como que a
gente participava aquilo e nem quando eu
fui convidado olha só o meu interesse em
comprá lá foi porque eu tinha minha
história me convidaram pra lá eu queria
participar eu estava fazendo novas
amizades também né
estava buscando espaço na sociedade
quando você passa por um problema
difícil é difícil a sua reinserção
social né ii
lá abriu o meu mundo oi todos já foi
todo esse caminho pra o que eu sou hoje
de fato né
foram quatro anos de ministério público
de fiscalização que eu entendi que um
conselho municipal tem mais poder de um
vereador muitas vezes mas a população
que deveria estar presente não está
porque a gente muitas vezes não procura
também espera que outras pessoas façam
vocês sabiam e aí já vou entrando nessa
questão dos conselhos que o tempo nosso
aqui é curto
essa frase foi uma das primeiras foi uma
das que eu mais usei lá porque todo
mundo vem me falar o seguinte
mas olha fernando sempre foi dessa
maneira e da câmara de vereadores agora
era o que eu mais escutava no primeiro
ano
mas sempre funcionou assim o faz a hora
a gente não é porque todo mundo foi
encerrado até agora que nós vamos nós
precisamos continuar errado então não
tornou isso certo porque todo mundo fez
errado
só que essa prática a gente falar não é
difícil porque é todo um sistema um
sistema que depende disso um sistema de
pessoas que estão ali recebendo salário
para participar do conselho pra votar de
acordo com que o poder executivo quer no
pará não atender à demanda da população
ea população ela está parada
ela está em casa e está sofrendo ela não
tem informação ela não sabe como
participar
e é por isso que você os jovens que
estão uma faculdade eu também sou jovem
que estão numa faculdade em podem
começar desde já gente desde os us vocês
têm os diretores escolares quando vai
ter eleição para líder da sala quem é
que se prontificar a seu líder da sala
ninguém
gente o mundo precisa de líderes
olha falta de audição que nós tivemos na
última eleição até o tranco ganhou nos
estados unidos gente porque não tinha
opção
o mundo inteiro precisa de novas
lideranças e nós somos essa nova essas
novas lideranças e pra mudar esse
comportamento e não é só assistir à
palestra né
é dedicação é um esforço diário é você
procurar você pesquisar é para você
entender
pra você ver de que maneira você pode
participar
e aí eu vou trazer pra gente aqui a
nossa constituição
se você não sabe a posição brasileira é
reconhecida mundialmente por que é
constituição cidadã ela tem garantido o
espaço para a participação do cidadão
como não tem nenhuma outra pelo mundo
afora e nenhum outro país do mundo se
garante tanto a participação do cidadão
1 enquanto aqui no brasil
[Música]
o que vocês acham que está faltando que
peça que está faltando gente é o cidadão
participar gen
não adianta ter um espaço e não vai aqui
nem reunião de condomínio
se você não vai na reunião do condomínio
você pode reclamar depois de trocar o
portão
não adianta você reclamar se você não
foi e você foi convidado a lógica é a
mesma
o prefeito é o nosso síndico da cidade
ele não toma decisões sozinho
existem os conselhos de direito
existem ao pão só voltar aqui e se que o
que a oposição disso todo o poder emana
do povo que o exerce por meio de
representantes eleitos o que eu sou um
exemplo disso ou diretamente nos termos
desta constituição além dos
representantes eleitos que não conseguem
trabalhar sozinhos também porque é uma
luta é uma batalha diária contra todo
esse sistema tem esses espaços que nós
vamos falar agora que é o controle
social
então toda decisão hoje a nível estadual
a nível nacional ea nível municipal tem
que passar pelo controle social o que
que é o controle social é o cidadão o
cidadão tem que dar o aval
só que existem as maneiras de dar o aval
então por exemplo a nível a nacional
estadual e municipal para cada pasta por
exemplo educação saúde assistência
social existe conselho nacional de
assistência social conselho nacional de
saúde
aqui em foz do iguaçu tem o conselho
municipal de saúde tem conselho
municipal de assistência social têm
conselho municipal de esporte tem
conselho municipal de cultura
vocês sabiam que esses conselhos que têm
que serem paritários metade do poder
executivo e metade da população ele tem
que validar cada ato do poder executivo
o prefeito não pode fazer nada eu digo o
prefeito como o chefe do poder executivo
mas o poder executivo municipal não pode
fazer nenhum ato de maneira arbitrária
ele só pode fazer aquilo que está
disposto em lei
diferente de nós que podemos fazer tudo
aquilo que não está proibido o poder
executivo e só pode fazer aquilo que
está permitido
só que quem permite somos nós só que nós
não estamos lá então nós não estamos
discutindo qual que é a melhor
estratégia de segurança grave lá pra
vila b para vilas e nós não estamos lá
para discutir sobre a fila da saúde para
discutir sobre que estratégia nós vamos
à a adotar para tirar as crianças da rua
e colocar o sport então é só a partir do
momento que a gente começa a participar
é que a gente vai realmente estabelecer
a democracia de fato no brasil nós
tivemos hoje um professor falando disso
aqui também que quanto mais democracia
melhor o país que nós vamos ter foi o
elton se une a nós temos também a
audiência pública pessoal uma audiência
pública ela pode ser chamado inclusive
pelos cidadãos vocês podem na câmara de
vereadores e dizer que iremos discutir
por exemplo agora nós vamos ter em
cascavel uma audiência pública sobre
tecnologia e as crianças o que foi
deliberado na audiência pública
deliberado vincula a atuação do poder
executivo ele não tem opção de não fazer
ele vai ter que me dizer quando ele vai
fazer ou me dizer que não vou fazer
neste momento porque não tenha dotação
orçamentária mas ele vai ter que criar
um cronograma para fazer isso
um caso em cascavel foi por exemplo a
temos um alto índice de suicídio
determinamos uma audiência pública com
participação do ministério público que
em três anos toda a atenção básica da
saúde deveria estar capacitadas no mês
seguinte a capacitação começou
só que nós tínhamos o auditório lotado
de pessoas interessadas naquilo a que
ganhou comoção popular ea audiência
pública que demonstra o interesse
público se vocês não sabem
um ato administrativo um simples assim
pura de um decreto do prefeito tem que
estar demonstrado interesse público não
pode agir por vontade pessoal
só que quando as pessoas não estão lá
para fazer o interesse público outras
pessoas que muitas vezes são amigos ou
que são lotados em secretarias em cargos
em comissão estão a demonstrando
interesse público interesse privado
então delas
vocês entendem pessoal e os conselhos de
política pública de políticas públicas
que é o que nós falamos nestes concelhos
e o exemplo é o comad que eu participei
se o conselho fala só não isso não vai
ser feito se o poder executivo fizer
aquela são o garante que o prefeito vai
preso
só que a gente não está lá pra falar num
não está lá nem para concordar nem para
discordar
nem pra debater sobre isso e aí nós
temos outras questões ainda como
plebiscitos referendos conferências
municipais enfim um jeito de participar
é o que não falta é falta cinco minutos
o um tom e agora é lá mesmo
então há a espero que vocês tenham
gostado é espero que fique essa reflexão
que cada um saia daqui com o propósito
de procurar uma maneira de participar ou
seja na sua faculdade formando se já não
existe um diretório acadêmico esse
diretório acadêmico pode fazer parte de
conselhos municipais e essa é a pergunta
é uma frase que ouvi do leandro karnal
que não existe governo corrupto com
sociedade honesta eu quero que fique pra
gente aí e agora o que nós vamos fazer
briga